what is up everybody hope you are living
well and living good it is Matthew
Springwood and Who am I with Oh David
Stone blog don't strike again and return
of the podcast broadcast is back how you
feeling I'm good how are you everyone is
listening to our fan mail episode yes
and apparently Dionne vs. Randy Moss is
becoming a thing a good combo that was
coming up we're still gonna have big
Phil yeah we're not doing a mascot
battle today
no mascot battle I mean we could do it
on the fly I'm disappointed I haven't
thought of anything okay and we're
having your guy Tim Bergsma right later
on yeah is this well he's a guy that's a
part of the neural neuro sports right
and they're they do a lot of stuff for
the brain I think it's something that's
really interesting it's gonna be the new
wave of the future and I always worked
with Kirk Cousins yeah he's worked with
a ton of NBA players right and he's
gonna be checking your brain later today
neural peak Pro that's the guts are
these guys like study brain waves in the
way that your brain works and I'm sure
it's great for NFL players after all the
hips yeah well it's great for that of
course just to see the status of your
brain and where it's at but it's really
for better quality of life too it's not
just a gonna be a sports agency what's
happened is just like just like CrossFit
professionals training like CrossFit and
then it catches on with the normal
public right I think this is something
that's why I was interested to bring him
on it's not just gonna be for sports
people this is going to improve
anybody's job quality of life sleep
ability to focus so I'm gonna get my
first assessment today too but yeah I've
had some people in the sports world tell
me about this guy and that's why I have
a feeling stay test your brain today
it's gonna be the first time that he
gets an echo whoa I've never seen this
much THC in a brain before so apparently
when we did our top five trios because
of Jarvis Landry it started something so
let's get into that okay Jarvis Landry
not happy that you didn't have the
Browns in the top five Mohamed Sanu not
happening right now commence kind of
made me that was a tough one though that
was fend Rick's fault yeah well no
vendrick was like I want to keep the
conversation going so I'm going to
comment in here that
newse an average number two which
apparently is what you said it is yes I
knew was like okay yes I know he's not
gonna like me anymore I think that's
gonna hurt that but yeah I do look at it
like this first of all I didn't give
rookie's a lot of love on the trio list
name is first of all for all those who
want to put tight ends in the Truitt's
wide reciever trios for all these that
don't read so well okay
they only didn't read it's unbelievable
I want to go you're making fun of me for
my trio and you literally can't read the
word wide reciever trio yet again some
people were like no I kind of get it
they have you know Travis Kelce with the
Chiefs and I'm like that's not that's
not it no it's not we've been total wide
receiver and I did not give rookies a
lot of love so I mean it's unproven to
this point I'm not gonna just throw them
out there now listen Julio Jones he's
the man Mohamed Sanu is very good he is
he's a solid number two but I think when
I am when I went through my list and
went through my head he's in the middle
of the road for number twos that's at
least where I had him and there's
nothing wrong with that I know he
probably thinks that's disrespectful but
yeah I think he's somewhere in that 14
to 16 17 range of number two wide
receivers so it was it was a good debate
Jarvis Landry I'll say this I should
have replied to this does he really
think I'm gonna put them as a top three
trio come on what I mean Johnny
suspension and Johnny I've been injured
my whole career along with him who
nobody wanted to sign him to be a number
one receiver except for the Cleveland
Browns he wants me to make them a top
trio I mean laughing emoji crying right
back at you oh you know emojis yeah
emoji cry so you were saying Corey
Coleman is the one that's chatty in
Jersey yes and then Josh Gordon is
Johnny suspension so I'm just saying I
can't put them in but if we want to do
another separate list of potentially the
top three best trios football well sure
like Cleveland at I think it was like
four or five because I think that Josh
yes it's exciting I get that but I tried
not to go with this I think rain it's
100% what we experienced with the
quarterback ranking yes a lot of people
use different metrics whether we're
looking towards the future and potential
or what you've already done or what
you're capable of doing right and I
think if there was a little bit of
people off it does throw people off
Tyree kill and Sammy Watkins it's a very
good duel yeah it's an incredible duel
and then people forgets Chris Connelly
was her last year Chris Connelly was the
eight hundred yard receiver the year
before he's not like some scrub I got
into an argument there because
somebody's like the Raiders and I was
like no the Raiders got three good ones
like there's not a lot of team that even
have three good ones no the rates that I
mean and I was like and I was like you
know it's Jordi and Amari Cooper and
martavis Bryant and they were like Mark
Davis Brian is a they called them
something I could forget it was and I
was like people forget what martavis
Bryant is capable of I mean he's a freak
of nature yes he truly is he is they
didn't the playoff game last year -
exactly right and then last year was a
weird year he didn't live up quite to
his potential because okay yeah he
wasn't there for a full season so that
changed things around jujube is there
he's getting himself back into football
shape but he does he is superstar
potential I don't think like any of us
would deny that and look 2015 season I'm
just looking it up real quick like yeah
I mean he had 15 yards per catch yet 50
receptions for 765 yards an 88-yard
touchdown and six touchdowns that was
last year that was in 2016 he didn't
play 17 no it was just an okay year he
had a he had a hard time early on
remember fantasy I know well yeah
because he's been missed him on some
wide open early then he dropped a few
and it just never got going juju emerged
right and he never really found his web
and he started publicly complaining but
he might get suspended I know I saw that
that was like as soon as the list came
out yeah I know all right so let's start
off with Kyle Shanahan okay he gave us
something or actually someone on his
team gave us something Joe Staley called
Kyle a next-level genius play caller it
was an article that you were quoted in
actually hmm you didn't see that I did
not see it I saw the I saw this comment
by Joe Staley I didn't read the artist
so Joe Staley said I've never been
around a play caller like him as far as
the X's and O's and just completely
understanding how every single piece
fits together he went on to say the way
he calls the play in a game to set up
something maybe in the third fourth
quarter down the road and how the
defense is attacking
he's like next-level genius stuff that
I've never been around the
for yes it's cool for everyone to start
seeing it right and this is what it
takes it takes you know the the decade
veteran to say something when people
really take it for real yes
you know when Marquis Goodwin says
something you go you're a wide receiver
but when the 12-year tackle vet says
something Kyle this is a great offseason
for Kyle yes it is I feel like we
normally spend our off seasons but
moaning about how he's not getting
enough credit right and now I feel like
this is the summer of Shanahan's yeah
summer of shinny and I think that people
are given the 49ers too much credit
right absolutely as a guy that yes
friends with this head coach I want to
be like pump the brakes on the
expectations here for my friend but
again this is a conversation you and I
have had a lot until he's a genius he is
and and what it takes like you said the
12-year veteran he can realize it
because he's going damn this guy makes
it easy on me I'm the left tackle he
makes me run block plays where I don't
have to be asked to do something that's
not realistic or so it's always an easy
like actual schematic block to get it
done he's not gonna be unrealistic he's
extremely creative not afraid to stride
different place and then we've talked
about through the years his knowledge of
the defense is what separates him in my
opinion he understands the rules of
everybody on the defense let me ask you
this question Kyle I feel like he's had
a chip on his shoulder now for about a
decade yeah
either he's coaching with his dad so
he's not getting full credit or he's
coaching in Houston credit or for like
two three years he had to kind of grind
down there in Atlanta yes in a year
where he's getting praised what kind of
of work ethic and and and practice are
we gonna get a Kyle right now guy never
wavers never it's a it's obsessive he
lives it just like I just think like you
know that's where you know I look at
guys like Kyle the same way I look at it
a Bill Belichick a Josh McDaniels a Sean
McVeigh the Sean Payton's of the world
two other guys that have these gifted
qualities that they have they live it
and never ends it's always in their
brain it's always thinking about a new
way to communicate with the team was
there ever a coach that that was living
it and then
living it ooh yeah there probably is
hold on I just got to think of that
that's that's a good one I feel like
there's been some defensive coordinators
over the years those guys who stopped
evolving right hmm
you know whether it's even being like
some of the West Coast offensive
coordinators we've talked about you know
even our guy Mike Martz Mike Martz never
changed it was great it was awesome
but then everybody got ahold of it he
just said screw it I'm still gonna do
seven so then drops and let my
quarterback hang back the other Jim
Kelly to Chip Kelly to write so it's
that type of guy where you just go ooh
Tampa 2 is awesome but at some point
everybody's gonna get it and we got a
change and that's what started the
Seattle cover 3 press bail right you
know because Pete Carroll and that staff
and Gus Bradley they were all in Tampa
my end of my career in Tampa everybody
still said we were a Tampa 2 team and we
used to laugh because we'd go we play
like 80% cover 3 but it's but we work
Tampa 2 and that's just what stuck with
it and that's really what the start of
the evolution was for that Seahawk cover
three deep oh well that's just the
public to the public latches it just
aren't terminologies they can't get rid
of it yes not to be outdone Gruden is
grinding rudin grind in but not John Oh
Jay Gruden so this is I feel like Jay
saw our story about Lil Wayne and Kyle
Shanahan and was like I will not be
outdone I am cool also yeah it's cool so
apparently Jay Gruden goes on jogs every
morning and that is his big thing that's
like his one time away it's when he
clears his head but on his jogs big-time
rap thin quote I love Gucci two chains
yeah Drake is okay but when he revealed
which rap album brought on the most joy
50 Cent's get rich or die trying' well
every song on that album was great when
he said it with a full smile yeah that
he used to listen to on his commutes
between Orlando and Tampa when he was on
the bucks 15 years ago
yeah quote I love 50 I knew all those
words by heart one completely agree
right can't rich or die trying' one of
the best all-time listen to it now and
you go every single one of these if it
came on in a
many man second if the reporters in
Washington don't just make him quote rap
lyrics they're doing a bright like get
up there and just be like give me 21
questions yeah just get him to give me
the questions you know all my heart J
but he's a sneaky assassin J he's sneaky
cool cuz he kind of just he's kind of
like just always kind of a chill guy
right he's not like his wired and
because he's chill or is he chill
because he would stand next to John and
you'd be like what compared to John no
yeah anybody's chill compared to jump
but no he truly is chill he is he's a
little more that way he's total football
guy brain going that way but not
necessarily just gonna always be in your
face and even back in that day he would
like cinnamon those Tampa days he would
say like little rap lines every now and
out of nowhere and you'd go oh damn J's
J knows what's going on a little bit he
say he's not as white and nerdy looking
as he dresses so he would just drop in
like yeah just say like some way away
right right he made it made him know
that he was aware of like so you believe
him oh I definitely believe him yeah
he's the type of guy that certainly
would listen to that got teenage kids
things like that I'm sure opening him up
to the hell different me was John and to
rap music John wasn't some rap music I
feel like John would be like the only
kinda music I like is the sound of the
pigskin he loved John loved hard rock
like he loved ac/dc ac/dc come in and
speak to us a night before a game once
what yeah I don't know their damn names
but there's really small guy that goes
around and like right I hear the smaller
players well he's like really small he's
like five three or five four but Gruden
loves ac/dc I think that was more his
type of music I know I'm horrible with
the names that come to guitar ac/dc his
name is out Angus Young yeah I feel very
stupid yeah I love ac/dc - so John was
how does I wonder how he gets into Ron
you picture though yeah because John's a
psycho and he was like damn and Jay is
like cool and he's just chilling in the
car with one
arm up and like many men wish death upon
me I can see that is amazing I do like
that I do like to be wet Drake is ok he
was like I love Gucci to chase man Drake
is okay and he is I want to go listen to
rap music with Jay Gruen with Jagger and
there would be a fun segment
yeah our show I think legs and ass what
up
so next week the ESPN The Magazine body
issues coming out oh did you hear who's
in it well c'est quand c'est quoi oh my
god I have I feel like well if you they
do this every year really some of them
picture of his booty and our podcast I
think it's definitely needs to go up as
we decorate the studio Odell you will
have company with your teammates don't
worry about it but I remember when they
said Vince Wilfer quit Fork was gonna be
in it
everyone's like oh I gotta see this say
Kwan's is going to be like we had people
tweeting at us like merry Christmas to
Sims se Kwang's the body is yeah it's I
hope they get a good angle oh I don't
think there's a bad angle I don't that's
the thing I mean this pictures I he's
gonna be jumping like it will be an
Edelman type of thing yeah I hope he's
like in the squat pose I wanna see full
legs flex a quad I want the quads like I
wanna see the definition uh I mean it's
pretty amazing again I'll say him
powerclean in that four hundred pounds
so you got to go watch that video if
you're listening to us it's worth the
YouTube to check it out it's one of
those things were like I had to envision
how hard that would be
it's like playing golf and realizing how
hard it is yeah or just like flicking it
all your own flicking it what all you
gonna do is just put the weight on that
bar and put it on the ground and just go
next to it and feel it a little and
you're gonna go I don't even get that I
don't even understand that how he did I
would break before that thing because
you pull it straight up right Casey
Hampton his senior and caught remember
Casey Hampton he was incredible
he's like Zeus - it means like his head
I didn't I never understood how it fit
into a helmet oh it's unbelievable he's
like Zeus from
what's the guy I'm good you know that
write down I know on Friday and Friday
after next you know like one I was
straight and what else am i crooked that
was Casey Hampton and Casey Hampton was
one of those like big not nice big guys
like he's not you know how I always say
like big guys are always gentle giants
because their moms like you're very big
be gentle with anybody don't scare
anybody Casey she never raised like that
it was like no just run him over if
they're in the way I'm okay and he was
in The Longest Yard I mean we got in my
recruiting visit he got into a
competition of take your shirt came in
with you know he was there already
because there's on I party I went to
and he went full Zeus mode there where
he took off his shirt and was asking
people to slap him as hard as they could
in the chest I mean and people were
going to town on him and what was he
doing he just swallowed it like and then
people were like okay do it to me back
and he started doing the people people
started folding like chanted like chairs
but he was you're you're a high school
kid I'm a high school kid I'm going and
I'm first of all I'm going near this
Texas place is cool look at this party
cuz that was my kind of party okay
everybody is together everybody having a
good time hey Christopher what does the
good text it was great these were just
slapping each other their shirts off it
was everything and he was such a psycho
and an awesome football player but he
did heat power clean he broke the school
record the year I was there and when he
put it on there I was like oh this crazy
mf'er is gonna get this it was like 4:30
for 40 and he power clean that
mother-effer up there and got it up and
then was so excited as we were he lifted
over his head he got it over his head he
didn't lock it out but he went like we
were all like and then he dropped it who
we were like what planet are you fun but
that just speaks we've talked about
Larry Allen and that video which is
infamous of my quadri I smell like
jumping on them and stuff as a football
team like I but I go to the gym or I
think when a lot of our listeners go to
the gym they're never they're not maxing
right but with you guys the numbers are
on the wall yeah yeah is it is it like a
competition is it a point of pride like
how long do you go like are you looking
overly
lifted more to me or do you kind of know
what each of your personal records are
you kind of know at college there's
competing with that stuff still but that
starts to end at college and then you
get the full NFL and you're still trying
to be strong and there's a max weight
look at this point people have their own
workouts yeah shredders peace with
yourself you're just like well damn
that's cool Mac and you okay he's
stronger than me oh that's nothing I can
do ease Khalil Mac or whatever College
it's still more College is still there
you're still more of the pride in the
numbers and like you said it's posted on
the wall yes the NFL you never really do
max where they're recording him because
they're so scared cuz the strength coach
is like well if I make Khalil max watch
600 and he blows out his back my ass is
gonna be fired to you right Casey
Hampton Casey Hannah I forget of all
these people that you've played yeah all
right let's get to the guy who's right
behind us if you're watching on video
it's this amazing mural of Odell Beckham
jr. let's get to our first whoa big
video got two videos for you okay
this one is Odell apparently at a camp I
love it and it says have you seen it
yeah I think I have but it's Odell I
love it oh my gosh this is unbelievable
okay yeah this is Odell that was my
first question it didn't look like it in
his hand
I don't think it was and then the other
ball he was catching with the one-handed
catches throughout the camp they had a
stripe on it still though no that's
that's why I say that's why I say
receivers are the greatest athletes on
the planet and my in my estimation my
first question was does this mean that
Eli Manning has a third strongest arm on
the junk well I think if you went for
pure distance yeah I don't think so
you're telling me it would go Davis Webb
Odell in some order
right and then Eli in terms of just
strength vote firstly yeah yes that
wouldn't be surprising just for pure
distance I wouldn't be surprised that
there's another receiver out there that
could throw it farther than Eli that's
not an indictment that goes on a little
more on teams and you would expect right
like Dan Marino had a really strong arm
but towards the end of his last five or
six years of his career meant he would
go to the NFL quarterback competition he
couldn't throw it past 51 yards right so
just because you could throw it a far
away
certainly mean you're a great passer or
thrower I thought I was incredible about
Odell was like the hop-step like it was
like an outfielder it really was it was
that's impressive the way he did it yeah
like I like I would trip over myself
like he did it more like a javelin throw
yes and it just the power and his
muscles his flexibility in his muscles
and his shoulder joint I mean I would
bet you that balm on 70 something yards
apparently went the length of the field
yeah and I believe he could probably
throw an NFL football over 70 yards or
around that like I really do
I've been around a few like Roy Williams
number Roy Williams in Texas seventh
pick of the draft by the Detroit Lions
he was the only guy I was ever around
pre spleen injury that I was threatened
by that could maybe throw the ball
farther than me so you believe that wide
receivers are the best athletes I think
so as a whole and ffs levers right well
and athletes are like that's it that's a
very good discussion right what are we
gonna say athletes are is it hand-eye is
it shooting basketballs there is it fast
explosive jumping to me I could I like
to combine both right and my receivers
have the best wide receivers for the
most part can shoot hoops can play
baseball I mean we've seen Odell right
we kind of all gone you seen his likes
right right so Dan think about what
we've seen Odell do this offseason he's
dunking basketballs he's hitting home
runs he's throwing footballs 80 yards
and he's showing up to practice yes man
yeah he's done everything and he said
he's going to training camp summer of
Odell yes by the way we've had 40 people
eliminated from our expect net baby
guessing when Odell's gonna get a
contract the entire front page if you
organized by date has been eliminated
just want to give a shout out to a few
of these people Matthew Fritz said he
was left goes 15th cousin he is not Ryan
McLane said he would take a bullet for
Chris Simms Thank You Ryan Jackson said
he was a number one obj apologist Zach
Spikers hashtag Phil Simms to the Hall
of Fame like it got a lot of stuff here
well I'm sorry to everyone that guessed
before June 20th Andrew Victor said this
competition was brought to you by long
[ __ ]
so hopefully your guesses are still
intact remember we will send now that we
have t-shirts some swag - whoever wins
our baby game yes another whoa big video
I'm sure that you've seen this and
talked about this - Terrell Owens ran
the 40 yes and Terrell Owens ran himself
a four four three
according to Julio's clock and a four
four five according to someone else's
I'm not gonna lie I recorded this on my
phone as well and I was getting in the
four threes and the four fours I just
what do you think about his stride we
think what the way he looks there looks
pretty good needs are flailing out to
the side a little bit but shows me he's
lost a little explosion alright sir this
I mean listen either way or four three
it's fast okay for 44 years old it's
incredible because this happens and then
people go why does no one sign him like
what like first of all right there's
there's a number of things here you
already said he's still going to be fast
yes that the issue is gonna be the
lateral quickness and the agility
explosion yes off the ball all those
things okay so there's a lot of things
here to question alright I'm not
applying I'm not I'm not accusing I'm
just questioning okay for everybody out
there first of all first accusation do
we know if that was 40 yards I don't
know exactly
second of all very convenient they
didn't put the camera at the finish line
so nobody could really time it right
okay that's another thing
thirdly it is a track okay it's a
freakin track fourthly it's hand time
combine as we know is lazer time sure
it's start hand start laser finish so
for 43 and a track I would say if we
went combine way especially on a turf
field and the laser finish
I'm gonna say is least four or five five
either way still really impressive
also he's not being drug tested not
accusing just saying Dan okay that
sounded like an accusation I'm just
saying he's 44 years old and he looks
really awesome and I don't know yeah but
just one guy if there's one guy that's
total major but 44 it's t8 I'm not gonna
let that stand
okay stand these last months it's been
crazy
I'm not saying
ever did at my plate he didn't have to
but I'm just saying he's 44 now and we
don't know yeah I'm not believing okay
but when when this happened yeah I mean
a parent look he was catching balls
apparently for the for the browns
I'm sure teams have looked into him I'm
sure you've said before there's zero
chance that he gets zero chance like I
think there's teams that are probably
somewhat intrigued but they just go damn
is it really worth it do we want the
press conference these are actions that
could like would jet like the Dallas
Cowboys and they're awful wide receiving
corps and Jerry Jones who they've
already dealt with them no no no you
know you're just you're gonna undermine
your new group of leaders - yeah you're
gonna oh there's Ezekiel and dak
Prescott take a backseat to the Hall of
Famer Terrell Owens now could tio say in
a meeting that could win a team over
like what would he act like if I was the
GM and you were Terrell Owens what do
you think he would have to say to win me
over gosh she's gonna have to just I'm
gonna be a Boy Scout I'm gonna do
everything possible I'm gonna talk to
the media once a week because it's
mandatory I'll make it quick simple make
the answers get out I'm gonna be a total
professional and I'm gonna do my best to
tutor some of your young players you
know you've got Johnny star at wide
receiver I can teach him some things and
the quarterback do you think GM's would
one Toyota because that's where we are
with Atlanta yeah I got parently Atlanta
Orlando Ledbetter said on ESPN Radio the
fact that he's running around this is
Julio Jones Terrell Owens has the front
office uneasy yeah yeah then it
continues the relationship between Jones
and the team is in a bad place right now
right well first why would it make the
Falcons uneasy because he's tio and he's
the king of the revolution okay what do
you mean well I mean he's just he's
always been willing to stake in the
ground about my talent and who I am and
I deserve this or whatever it may be
he's been that guy he has not been
afraid to speak out whether those the
Eagles the Cowboys the 49ers whatever it
may be and they're going damn
here's Julio Jones starting work with
that workout with him he's got three
years left on this contract and now he's
kind of speaking out without speaking so
I think they're worried about that now I
get that but again
Julio Jones is using the tools available
to him to get what he wants and what he
deserves
and I applaud him for that because he's
not the eighth best receiver in football
he's you nanus italy unanimously top
three and everybody's list and folk yeah
right I'd say he's probably top two
right I feel like everyone changes
whether they're Antonio Brown or Odell
Beckham or AJ green or whatever but then
they always or DeAndre Hopkins they
always say Julio if you like I think
you're right so top two fine so there
there you have it now again there's good
things if Atlanta of Atlanta's I mean
Elena is also there's good things I mean
T yo you see how much GA pees in it so
that was my thing is don't you think
tío working out with Julio like they're
going to be like Julio is gonna be in
great great shape he's in a wide
receiver III know my dad actually tio
stays healthy almost his entire exaction
right there's lots of little tricks of
the trade at wide receiver different
wide receiver coach have little
different drills little different
nuances they can teach you about route
running yes
so there is stuff to be learned there
yeah taking care of your body for the
future all those things but what Atlanta
doesn't like is on that car ride over
there to the workout he's going Davante
Adams is making five hundred thousand
more than you oh gosh who else is making
more money oh there's seven other guys
that aren't as good as you they're all
making more money so let's play are you
are we sure are we sure are we sure
apparently Quinn was expecting him to be
there and then a few weeks later Julio
told him he's not going to be there and
that the relationship between Julio and
the team is in a bad place right now
yeah
are we sure this is gonna end well I'm
getting a little feeling right now and I
I'm not gonna put this on Tio's feet
right I'm not gonna say T ough cause
this right I've been noticing that Julio
has been putting himself in the media
more and more yeah I think there's a lot
of stars that they get paid and that
some of them go why am I not getting
national attention yes jr. all over the
place he goes why am I not getting that
and I'm in Atlanta right this is a major
market so I think that he's always been
wondering this but I'm not sure this is
gonna end well I think before I would
have said Julio has always been a nose
to the grindstone not worrying about
stuff
but now I'm looking at all the tea
leaves and this they need to pay him cuz
I don't think he's gonna come in I don't
think he is especially when I'm getting
bleacher report alerts that sarkeesian's
on the hot seat if the offense doesn't
improve yeah so Julio is now looking at
the Falcons like this my quarterback
just got paid twice as much as I do and
I've made his career yes my my offensive
coordinator
I see what a good offensive coordinator
is the tackle for his new team calls him
a next-level genius play caller and my
offensive coordinator is on the hot seat
because he might get fired and he's
looking around he's going they just
probably tried to draft my replacement
in Calvin Ridley I would like some
security I don't like everything that's
going on right well and then this is the
other thing that kind of bothers me but
this is the other thing I hear about
with this conversation I mean there's
two things first of all people go well
he's hurt a lot he's not as hurt as much
as everybody thinks like let's let's
look it up okay I'm gonna tell you
because he's he missed some games two
years ago but after that it's not as
many he hasn't been able to practice a
lot during weeks but people he balls out
in plays and here I'm gonna show you
just as far as games played
he missed okay 2013 he only played five
games - all right so there was that his
rookie year he only played 13 games 2014
he played 15 games oh he missed one game
how dare he 2015 16 games 2016 14 games
2017 16 games so that crap about he's
always injured it's a book that's like
[ __ ] I don't want to hear it anymore
yeah he's not he's banged up a lot he
can't practice on Wednesdays but he
balls on Sundays like he'll say yeah and
again I just I don't understand they
push back why does anybody not mad at
Jerry Jones for did they had a contract
with Dez Bryant why did any honor it I
don't understand what a jerk he is he
didn't honor it that to me is driving me
crazy with Bill Polian go on that ranch
yeah well he's ridiculous it's nonsense
it's not as the players podcast I don't
even think we're going on a limb
contracts are so one-sided that for you
to say and they're either openly
one-sided that for anyone to say you
should out of the contract
that's its that is such a dumb argument
that I don't even want to acknowledge I
know so the true thing is is I I do
agree that Julio unfortunately is going
to be a lesson for a lot of people and
Kirk Cousins showed us the result of
that lesson three-year deals yeah if you
want to only trust us for three years
then don't I my ego does not need to
have a big number four years four and
five and six that I might not see right
just give me my three right and if you
want to lock in long term then make
those years guaranteed - yeah sure but
the problem is I think they go we're
gonna make you the highest-paid wide
receiver and the total number is gonna
be 98 right but you're really only gonna
see 16 oh yeah and then they use your
your your I don't even know what I want
to say your love for football against
you like Aaron Rodgers and Julio Jones
well if you give us six years it'll
lower the cap number and these guys are
like well they want to win they want to
be good teammates they want to play
because they want to be all-time greats
yes and then they bowed the team and
nobody ever takes that into account that
they did that for the team and now here
they are wanting to be you know a paid
accordingly and people are mad about
that either way Julio Jones I mean he
has the right and he should do this and
I just I'm like you where does this end
up do they reach out now I don't know if
they rip it up I'm gonna go they go
Gronk way like New England did last year
right that's how you feel and we're
gonna throw in some incentives and some
bonuses guarantee yes exactly right that
are probably gonna be pretty easy for a
guy like him to accomplish to where he
can get an extra eight five million
dollars a year something like that
to me it feels two things one I'm
reminded again of the show billions
which I just caught up to and it's great
but every one of that show is asking for
favors and I'm always like you're asking
for so many favors like you're gonna
lose track I feel like that's and
contract negotiations these guys like
help out the team and they do a favor
and they're never there never
reciprocated Oh like only quarterbacks
are rewarded for that Tony Romo Tom
Brady Drew Brees they get paid back
later yeah I don't feel like anyone else
does he does that's another reason
everybody doesn't like the quarterback
the other thing is too is I think about
relationships if you've ever been in a
relationship and in the beginning you
know we're super casual and it's a lot
of fun
and oh wow like Julio is just he's so
loyal and he doesn't ask for anything
whatever okay well we're like seven
eight years in now Julio's changed yeah
people in relationships change and I I
don't think that it's as if they thought
Julio was never gonna speak all right I
was never gonna ask for any he won't
even notice that Sammy Watkins is making
two million more than him it's it's
crazy no of course he's going it's
almost it to me insulting that they're
like well Julio you've been so quiet
yeah yeah
now reward me for being quiet years ago
okay but you know that when you gave me
that contract years four five and six
we're not gonna be the same right and
Terramax he could have probably dealt
with it until he saw that his
quarterback was gonna make more than
double of him and then he was like okay
I'm officially insulted now now it's got
a chance I think it was the perfect
storm the wide receiver market had a lot
of it wasn't a great for agency class so
guys like Sammy Watkins got more money
than him right Jarvis his quarterback
got double his money and then was called
the face of the franchise we've argued
before I think Julio is a fan of the
franchise and then his offensive
coordinator sucks yeah so he gets to
camp and he's like I don't want to run
this dumb offense like two years ago
with Kyle I could do whatever I wanted
and now I'm covered yes
all right let's get Phil in call Phil's
gonna help us with Lamar Jackson oh cool
cool that's what you're gonna go with
this yeah all right we'll do a little
quarterback talk yeah good I noticed
that you're wearing Phil's what I am
wearing Phil's watch today I just
thought it went nice with my outfit
today this is Phil's most valuable
player Super Bowl twenty-one phil simms
watch yep
so was that bestowed upon you he gave it
to me he did yeah I do I wear it with
pride I don't wear it much but that's a
pretty good one oh hello dear dress dear
Drew's first appearance the sims Aleph
Copa you're on the podcast what are you
doing nothing are you waiting for you
turning a dad yeah I'm trying to get dad
yes what a dummy all right wait where's
that these are crazy are you kidding me
no so all right so we'll call the cell
okay question how is the planning
for the draft party at Phil's house good
job okay any any tidbits for the
listeners ice sculptures maybe no just
surprise all surprises all surprise that
was Dierdre Dierdre Sims Thank You
Deirdre thanks here all right so let's
still he's working out Phil Simms
he's benches up so we're gonna call his
cell now guys the other nut all the
other number what uh what's he been ssin
I don't know two squad knows he's going
over there too okay here he is yeah work
guess we're calling yourself yes thank
you for telling us that gosh
I'm kind of a believer that he gave you
that watch when I guess about a year and
a half ago maybe was it like a birthday
or something um no you know what I think
it was Christmas my my hope and I hope
this isn't the real thing right I hope
he was like oh [ __ ] it's Christmas I
forgot to give him something I'll give
this watch no this is actually something
I think he would have thought about I
think the original was ruined and he got
the NFL to remake it or redo it yes yes
hey Phil is that you yeah I'm listen you
guys are riveting I just and I just
could I was on every board going this is
great stuff I'm talking about your watch
maybe watch that Chris's whoa I just
heard a little bit he well he was trying
to claim that you probably didn't get me
a Christmas gift that year and you just
said oh oh [ __ ] alright here's the watch
things like that with you okay yeah hey
you're not sad we know yes thank you my
gosh just don't feel it you don't like
Phil Mickelson it and out there
Shinnecock I'm sorry I didn't feel it
yeah you guys well you're going to the
gym right now though right I am I'm
sitting in the parking lot right now
what's the Phil Simms workout
so you and Phil how old are you right
now I'm just gonna do nothing but I'm
gonna do the Adam Lepke workout today
I'm gonna do a lot of arms and more arms
and channel get the Freak look look at
me I'm in shape right now Phil will be
63 in November so there's a lot of guys
that listen they want to know what
Christopher eats and what he does for a
workout I'm being serious
what is the Phil Simms workout today how
much whey do we push him what are we
doing at 63 athletic knowledge you know
the world of wellness and he said to me
he goes
Phil after age yeah I got you yeah so
yeah so I try to act my age I changed
the way I work out I do about a hour and
15 minutes and I just stay very busy I
do not lift heavy weights on anything
anymore
it's over Wow but do you love how like a
stranger tells and that and he listens
but when the sons tell him that stuff
for the last six years
he just says ah screw you too what do
you know but stranger person sure I'll
listen to him yeah qualified to tell me
and they knew you're right what am i
doing Phil what do you listen to when
you work out or do you listen to rap
music when you work out oh when I walk
in this gym here in a few minutes if
there's rap music on you know the first
thing I do hey hey turn it off
so what do you put on he does nothing I
don't care what they put on you're not
listening to Bruce Springsteen or Bon
Jovi no and you know they're not cursing
at me and all this sends no new
motivation I came in and they're I don't
know who it was and then
music I was like hey who put this on and
I just walked a man you gotta take this
music off it's not right
improper dude you're the worst if you
came up to me or likes topless and I'd
be so upset well who controlled did you
guys have like radio stuff and your
locker room back in the old days and the
Giants and like the way version like who
controlled that stuff okay but who was
her guy in the LA I was elevated wasn't
long because he never went in the weight
room so we'd have to worry about that
you know what was great I think I was 38
years old so a song would come on in
music or in the weight room and
everybody look at me go 20 bucks says
you don't know who this is
you know and I'd go so-and-so whatever
and you know I'd be right about half the
time and wrong half the time so they
thought that was really funny that I
wasn't but you know the 22 year old guy
is asking me you know the new song that
he likes right I'm not listen to it
right but I hung in there pretty good is
you know for my age I mean I think I
knew more than I really I guess more
right than wrong let's look that way
have you ever partied with a musician
before I was at Bon Jovi's house for a
big fundraiser one night but I didn't
get the party with him or nothing like
that because it's because there was too
many people there but it was a pretty
interesting beautiful group of people if
you know what I mean who are you no
actually I'm actually interested in this
whose if you just think about your
career all your days playing everything
who was like the one star you met
through your career where you were like
wow this is pretty cool or you were
actually even starstruck by well well
yep that's right well you've met a few
presidents I mean you used to go to
Britain Richard Nixon's house for lunch
what
right oh you know he was kind of over he
was a giant fan set up in the scan they
set up in the top deck which I thought
was really cool so we had lunch and then
when lunch broke he looked at his wife
okay you take the room in that room the
man come with me in the other room and
you know pretty you look so he goes home
or just leave tomorrow no way it was
like right out of this house somebody
was imitating them every trait we talk
football but a few other things and he
was so kind and I did meet Arnold Reagan
I was invited to a state dinner or saw
went there and I said the same table as
George Bush Wow
so that was pretty cool because he was
at the table and you don't get to sit
with your wife it's boy-girl-boy-girl
and you said with a different group of
people nobody sits with your wife
girlfriend or boyfriend her husband huh
and George Bush was really cool he just
leaned out the minimal table goes now
listen I know some of you were nervous
but don't worry about protocol just
reach and get it and just have you know
let's eat you know I was cool cuz I was
sitting there going well do what do I do
here you know really it was a good time
this is probably not as funny to people
because of what has happened or
transpired since then but when the
dinners over they just push the cattle
into another room and of course the
president all the people that don't want
to be part of you they all leave when
they have a band there a music plane and
you dance and carry on and I just
remember Joe Paterno was there right and
Joe Paterno got on top of a table and
was dancing oh my gosh that is amazing I
can't even picture was he a good dancer
he was really good what that's who he
was you know when the coaches would have
to Benson's even go out and he'd this
would have a great time so the you know
it's just we all have a thought or who
we perceive
somebody to be even you get needs
different atmospheres or whatever
not half as fierce I sought to work for
it but all and then they you care to see
who they really are right all right so
I'm gonna since we're paying you so much
money Phil I need to get some work out
of you okay we're gonna talk about Lamar
Jackson and apparently he has a nurturer
rg3 says quote I'm trying to nurture him
as much as I possibly can so that when
he flies away he is ready to fly away
because when you watch it fly away at
that point it's up to the bird that's
what rg3 said I think I saw it with my
son oh yeah yes I think they were
talking about that alright so what do
you think is rg3 the one to nurture yes
okay well you know what oh good yeah I
mean right it's a politically big time
absolutely the thing that you should
that you say that is what everybody
wants to hear in the organization right
and now if he's doing it for real you
know his actions are gonna speak a lot
bigger than those little words he needs
to the press but I think he realizes
that's the that's how you survive you
know I've been talking to a lot of
people here lately
and they don't think that Lamar Jackson
oh he's not going to play probably the
whole year I go excuse me so I got some
waiters out there yeah in the shotgun
receiver running back everything in the
first game right and and I put a number
of five on it I thought no there's no
way I got home and I said whatever let's
just say the bet was a thousand bucks
I'm not going to amorously bet right I
said I'll tell you what give me nine
hundred dollars right now and I'll let
you have a bet
yes sir dad I've heard you say that so
you think that he gets dad thinks he
gets at least five
snaps at the true quarterback position
the first game not just that receiver he
thinks somehow either hinders center or
shotgun but he will be the quarterback
on at least five plays in game on the
year and I wouldn't bet it I wouldn't
bet it with dad because I think right
now the way we see and read between the
lines and what we hear out of their camp
and things like that that I think that's
yeah that's dicey he's gonna be out
there at least five plays I think Flacco
agrees with Phil Flacco's rounding up
wide receivers to throw in the offseason
for the only the second time in his
career in the first time was because the
lockout that's right so I think he's
ready to lead money you need right
you need more give this up and I don't
blame him it's a great position power
position get a lot of money
adulation everything else there's
nothing like being the starting pro
quarterback but it doesn't matter
because offense there's so much about
what deception what's coming next make
the defense think and you know because
they don't want to and so they're gonna
use him at worse just as a decoy I would
think the first time his first snap
under center or in the shotgun he's
gonna take the football and hand it off
right because that will tell them okay
how they're gonna playing once the
coverage is going to be and then they'll
have a ray of plays all that that goes
with it and sometimes I think he'll be a
receiver he might be a receiver on the
backfield Joe Flacco throw them a little
screen and then let's see what happens I
like that I like that a lot of ideas
that's for sure yeah I like that prop at
five quarterback snaps and week one I
like that one yes Phil I've never
included you in whoa big offseason
before so whoa big phil season Josh
Allen a lot of people love them
apparently a wide receiver at camp is
Austin parole son of Rocky Pro yeah he
said cam has a strong arm because he
used to be a ball boy for cowboys and
Cam Newton has a strong arm I was a ball
boy used to have catches with him all
the time and at first I thought
nobody could be can but throwing with
Josh and seeing the wall
ball come out of his hands it's close I
can't I don't know it's close is it
possible that Josh Allen has a stronger
arm and Cam Newton oh I don't know if
it's possible I'm blowing the bet like
well I'm in a better mood today you
aren't seriously no he's got a strong
one you can do you do believe that I do
I do I agree with it it's I mean hey
listen we're not trying to throw shade
on Cam Newton because I think dad and I
will say it's it's great right I mean
he's got an arm that he could throw it
so hard he can make receivers not catch
the football
yes yeah but no Josh Allen is I think
like we said in the drought it's the
strongest arm I've ever seen and that's
I think it's saying something it's not
doesn't mean he's the best quarterback
or the best rover but it's stronger than
Aaron Rodgers and Patrick mahomes and I
thought mahomes was the strongest arm I
ever saw coming out of college since
I've been in this business so yeah I
would agree with that sentiment Phil I
mean you've got to see a quarterback
play forever right jerky quick thrower
you know all that Jesse Allen is is
smooth and he can just
he's won on tall all those things and he
can just get through the football so
just as workout if you watch this code a
but rarely on the NFL Network was just
terrible you know you didn't throw this
button well yeah I don't know anything
right but he threw some balls I don't
know they were trying to judge him on
the air but he they were going at least
80 yards yeah they were Oh what
everybody throw distance throws for real
and I've always seen I saw John Elway
Dan Marino all this and that and oh by
the way I threw it farther than Dan
Marino him I was snow and in China a
person I've ever seen throw the football
80 yards for real or it's Brett Favre
right I thought I told a ball 81 yards
at the quarterback challenge and
a little of line but I was just like oh
my gosh it makes your arm hurt watching
ability just put everything into it but
81 yards and Josh Allen can be that and
you know what look at the players what
they're tweeting out exactly and I've
talked and I love the article Oh Nathan
Peterman could be the starter up here
well yeah well tell them what you think
you just tell them your I was gonna
bring that up so micro dak said that
Peterman should be considered a serious
contender for the starting job he'd
split first cam and I can't wait to hear
your guys reactions he also completed 10
of 13 passes big dad dad's got the right
response here I think dad's all over
this when he said it I was like you're
exactly right that's it go ahead well I
mean to me that was what we talked about
it a little I don't know if you remember
but yeah I mean it's it's that's NFL
team propaganda it's probably good
they're just trying to pump the brakes
on the island let's talk about the other
guy right take the pressure off of them
yeah oh and they're gone they want to
make it look like he earned it right we
didn't just give it to him he beat out
some of the guys that were here we were
trying to make it be a redshirt year but
he was so good ok that's great and you
know see see this is the these things I
I just got to tell you I hate I'm gonna
do I hate it and come on it's a little
big off see all of it get him ready and
we're gonna push him and we hope he's
the opening day starter because he's
gonna be our starters question to win so
why don't we have to go make him earn
his way oh oh come on come on you you've
been watching practice I haven't seen
the practices but I've talked to some
people - bender these things you know
the tweets for the players and it's
quite evident the talent is extremely
substantial right and let's don't forget
Justin run around - yeah so and he's
built for Buffalo because I don't care
what we say well the to worse weather
for other cities in the NFL who is
clearly one is number two that's right
yeah so but you know just what you're
right let's calm it down you don't throw
some propaganda after all they compete
them in there's still in this race and
everything and you know what I don't
know I'm just saying if he wins the job
then okay why is this just for fun come
for funsies here because you were on the
on the subject I just be I would love I
don't think I've ever heard you answer
this either so I mean you've seen all
these guys in person all these great
throwers in history let's just stay I
don't know you can correct the list but
I know you've seen Favre in person and
practice you just played against Elway
you saw him in practice Aaron Rodgers
like when you when all said and done you
know stack them up for us as far as what
about them as throwers who had the
strongest arm you know just the that
kind of thing or is there somebody I'm
missing that you think needs to be in
this conversation
Jeff Marino there for a few years he was
an incredible thrower
right when his legs and body and he was
in shape and man he had great footwork
and he could just be powered the ball
and he was truly incredible right and of
course John Elway speaks herself just
could drive the football you know of
course its movement man just you know
just think about Dan Marino and John
Elway and guys like that what kind of
numbers do you think they put up in
today's game right gosh right in person
many times I said I am witnessing the
best arm in the history that I'll ever
see in football and then of course they
that's all here in Rogers and I never
forget this third year didn't play but I
saw him in training camp and I just I
just remember going all my gosh his arm
is better than Brett Favre's and it was
it's like she just changed overnight but
other names you know I saw this guy
throw in person he never gets mentioned
because his career was cut short but
bird Jones he has incredible burn shows
number seven on the call ex back in the
70s yeah yeah that ruined his career but
he could throw it I watched him
warm up before we played them in 1980 in
an exhibition game and he was sorta
behind his head like forty and fifty
yards about five feet harness going oh
my gosh you know it was really
incredible yeah I've heard you know guys
gonna say I've heard you say that before
about him that he was one of those guys
that you always thought was super
talented well you remember they had an
old-timers quarterback challenge over in
Hawaii and Bert Jones went over and and
participated in it and Bobbie Beathard
said I want to take him and try them out
and see if he wants to come back at the
time I just tells you you know Bobbie
better they've seen a lot of great
throwers right right and he said they're
watching Bert Jones going oh my gosh
yeah it's truly different even from some
of the best quarterbacks in the NFL at
the time when he said this now this has
been quite a few years but I remember
that thinking going yep not surprised
I'm sure he can still come on I bet you
to this day he could go out there and
pull it around and still make you go WOW
because think about him big long arm
long arms yeah shoulders yeah athletic
could really run I mean he had
everything and then you know to a guy we
never talked about that we should you
know Terry Bradshaw what mean he wasn't
walking flour yeah I know you're right
we talked about like he's chopped liver
I'm here he went for dough in Super
Bowls but but you don't Terry didn't
complete enough percentage of his passes
so he just wasn't accurate enough you
know the analytics tell us that I never
saw him Terry throw a ball under 30
yards oh I watched him warm up I was
there after my rookie year without the
Los Angeles to the Super Bowl oh the
watch the Super Bowl right and I'm in
the end zone he's right in front of me
warming up and he is throwing the
football and I mean it I just call he is
smoking it and there was like a ball boy
or equipment manager that the other one
captured it and giving it to Mike Cruz
check who's the backup quarterback right
Boston College and he throw them and the
poor ball our equipment manager one
comes right at his head he misses it and
I
it hits him square in the forehead and
Down Goes Frazier like you know okay you
never got a chance but I just went oh my
god it was it was great of course he
threw some great passes in that game
that he did he won the game for him
that's right
we leave him out I know very bad shawl
he was six foot four probably about 230
pounds when he came out of college it
mode I'm sure he was a four or five
forty guy he is he's a freak
he is you're right he is he's a big guy
Adam and you know I don't mind putting
my hands on people and kind of you know
yeah you better watch out there you go
man when he puts those hands on you're
like wow get off of me they are there's
that I mean just came he's strong you
know he's unbelievable and I don't care
how old he is right now still with what
a miserably
so but those are just some of the guys
they always that group you talk about
Jesus jump out and yeah the other guy
that had an unbelievable arm
unbelievable was Daryle Lamonica
oh yeah the old Raiders quarterback
watch it with anybody right number three
back in the old days oh man I mean it
was truly bombs away it was out Davis it
and I could just see him sitting up in
his suite going oh wait hold it you know
it's dog deep one-on-one coverage and
that's it that's our football team man
that was awesome man when you go and
lift put the ass on the grass that's all
you need to know put the ass on the
graph yeah when you're doing your squats
because I know you're not going to give
up on squats you know I'm really true
Murphy
retiring people right walking the
treadmill
yes few curls that's right go do so I
was practicing that I was practicing not
interrupting and quiet and it upset Phil
so much that he thought maybe I didn't
know yes that big now that always
interrupts me what do i do why I have a
trainer so he takes me around but
because do you know what you want to
know what I needs it yeah it's like I
know this is this is a guy that gets
distracted by anything he'd be in the
middle of a bench press and I have to
answer an Instagram post real quick and
that's forget you know where you know
what I'm saying the fill in all of em oh
yeah I should have known if I prevented
a trainer to him that we should have
Phil Simms trained me oh well yeah that
would be great that would be great for
him well I'm you be awful for me well he
doubt he doesn't he is he's got some
injuries so he's trying to dial it back
a little bit apparent and he he's
hilarious because truly I would say he's
gonna be 63 like I said November six
seven years ago when we would work out
you know we would work out I beg damn I
mean dad hanging like unbelievable then
I'd be like damn dad it's gonna be me in
this exercise I can't do as many as he
can everything but then in the last like
two or three years man we all when we
work out together we only do the
exercises he's good at and we only do
his work out since I'm always like oh
okay it's always the exercises that he
feels like he might be able to beat me
in yes we're gonna do all those so that
worked out tonight hey Dad I squatted
yesterday all over I'm squatting today
so we're gonna squat again okay great
I like that Phil is tired of the whoa
big offseasons that's what it is the
stories that come out so I have a few
honorable mentions the first one that
was shot at Josh Allen yeah some
honorable mentions Eric Ebron is Denton
done turning heads in Indianapolis
that's right he's fast and smart Elisha
Maguire compared to a Hall of Famer
yes LaDainian Tomlinson Elisha Maguire
from the Jets quote he has the skills
get set to be LaDainian Tomlinson came
from running backs coach stump Mitchell
he told David Johnson the same thing I
will be honest I don't think that's
crazy
I saw Elijah McGuire he's got some
talent he is he's very talented you're
right he's the reason that Bilal Powell
owners were so upset in fantasy last
year because Elijah McGuire is really
impressed he is really impressive still
a woven golf I know the Jets are one of
those team you look at the running back
by committee it's pretty I mean him our
four well that's already damn good three
yeah we're gonna do best running back
duo's and they made my preliminary list
yeah right another honorable mention a
wide receiver that's a three then as the
talent to be a one yes
Kenny gala day Golden Tate says if he
can keep the mentality has studies tries
to get better I'm telling you he can be
dominant he's a wide receiver one kind
of guy whoa big offseason yeah yeah yeah
this is what they were saying about him
last year he did here to fight injuries
I don't know if he's not wide receiver
number one I'll say he's he has
potential to be wide receiver real good
number two that's for sure I need to see
a little more than the Josh Thaksin
class of I see what you got yeah that's
see more yeah and then veterans lobbying
for a rookie whoa big offseason
apparently veterans came up to defensive
coordinator Greg Williams of the Browns
and said Denzel Ward needs to be playing
more and this is what Williams
apparently had a conversation really now
you're gonna take ownership of them oh
really now you're mentoring him we'll
see
I'll give them a couple reps out there
and we'll see after that you give the
kid the reps and I don't anoint anybody
but both him and miles Garrett got the
acceptance of everyone faster than most
rookies have had so apparently dens
outwards playing well that is that's
that's a good sign because the players
usually don't miss on those type of guys
right
Gregg Williams is not letting anybody
get praise that doesn't deserve
definitely not so that that is that is
encouraging to hear about Denzel war
that means that he is going out there
and impressing people on the defensive
side of the ball and going oh wow those
are special movements by that guy right
there they're better than the other guys
we have he needs to be out there yes but
the second whoa big offseason the real
one Todd Haley says about his
quarterback room it's probably the one
of the best if not the best quarterback
rooms in general that I've had what do
you think about that you're smiling I
mean you know I I don't know I mean no
room with Big Ben's ever gonna be the
best room okay cuz he's tough to deal
with so it's probably a little shot at
him certainly I also feel like Tyrod
Taylor and Baker Mayfield are trying to
be each other's best friends yeah
everybody right well III mean did you
hear about the reports out of Cleveland
today right just as the Baker camp
that's what we said yeah that's right
it's just I I'm not trying to say we're
right but this is not just from the
Pires aspect this is what I was scared
about when they picked him number one
because I they're just the players are
gonna go okay yep same sizes Baker
Mayfield Tyrod Taylor Oh
tire rods got a little stronger arm Oh
tie rods a little faster damn why don't
we pick this guy number one yeah so I
think there's all of that also to the
fact that Cleveland's probably pumping
the brakes a little bit like they've had
a lot of these young quarterbacks
they've thrown them in there early and
it's become a disaster and it has their
careers so John Dorsey probably realized
that he's trying to take his slower
approach cuz he has to make this work if
this doesn't work he this will live on
his gravestone the Browns have a very
talented team yes the fact the Browns
are favored over a number of other NFL
teams to get to the Super Bowl like
they're not last there in the middle and
a third of their division so let me ask
you this yeah John Dorsey he goes out
there and let's say Denzel Ward's great
and a lot of their other picks work out
and this team makes a playoff push with
tie rod TAS let's say they're actually
end up being really good over the next
five years but Baker Mayfield is never
able to beat out tie rod tail yeah well
it's gonna happen no my happens to John
Dorsey yeah I did do Baker Mayfield at
some points that's the pick they're
gonna beat him and he's gonna beat him
out whether they have to get rid of tie
rod Tara
like a buffalo did this past year but if
the Browns end up being good and Baker's
not a part of it
is it still successful yeah it could
still be successful yes it can be your I
could have Brad depends on the quality
of what Baker Mayfield does when he gets
out there but yeah yeah I mean it's a
huge pick and they have to make sure it
works because it's just always if it
doesn't work everyone's gonna go you
picked a 6-1 218 pound coin for 85 and
has nine-inch hands at the number one
player in the draft oh you thought that
was the big off state I was gonna be
this year the actual whoa big offseason
is Todd Haley talking about Tyrod quote
his car is there every morning in his
spot when I get here in the morning and
it's there when I'm leaving that's what
you're looking for the leader of your
offense yes it is parking lots man
marking Lots that's really all you have
to do as a football player is be there
before the coach and you're working hard
they don't know what you're doing there
before they get there but man they've
car was there he's there in this right
spot he probably he wasn't out late he
was focused to get high like that he
backs it in so that he's prepared he's
planning ahead he's backs it in yes
never over the line I know I go back and
I wish the wheels are straight it's
something that makes the coaches feel
warm and cozy it really does it's
hilarious it's like I go back to my dad
a little bit because my dad one year
Bill Parcells told them like in the
offseason just come in and fake it more
let the guys see you walk into a meeting
room with five tapes like you're gonna
go in there watch me because I don't
give a damn if you go in there take a
nap but when the guys see you do it it
becomes infectious and everybody wants
to be there a little earlier doing it so
I get that
all right last whoa big offseason right
is more funny about everyone else's
perception of this guy Case Keenum is
the bonafide leader of the Denver
Broncos defensive end Shelby Harris says
you have a bonafide leader if one guy
that you can look towards this is our
guy for the reason don't get me wrong I
thought Trevor Simeon was a great
quarterback I thought he did great
things I think Paxton is a good
quarterback but when you have a
quarterback battle it's like who takes
the reins
who's the one who steps up but this year
with case
we have our leader you have a guy you
can go to but Lavoie all of a sudden
Case Keenum mr. I have to fight for
everything mr. I'm always in quarterback
battles and no one will ever trust me
now he's on a team and people are going
we finally have our leader yeah whoa
Case Keenum is a leader I just think
it's funny that last year we had a
shamrock up his ass and now he's the
real leader of robot it's the tone set
by the head coach and Zimmer would never
give him credit to be a leader or the
guy that was actually accomplishing
plays out there on the field with his
physical prowess apparently though it's
also like Demaryius Thomas comes to the
helm be like all were fixed like we got
we forgot in case it was I got it yeah
and he does it and apparently the whole
team is like that it says to me more
about Trevor Simeon than it does about
case sure yes Kings a stronger
personality yes yes definitely annie's
he's coming off a year where he should
feel confident and feel like he belongs
and he can do it again and hey listen
Denver their defense we know it's good
damn I mean who would you take digs or
Thielen or Emmanuel Sanders or Demaryius
Thomas it's good conversation right
Emmanuel Sanders you gotta remember he
was hurt last year
I mean Demaryius Tim Thomas I know he's
been a little disappointing but it's
still like 900 a thousand yards every
freaking year so he's got something
there they can be one of those teams to
have snow that's hard discussion oh
right it's a hard discussion right I'd
take Tim arias no man I would - I know I
know it's so there's potential with that
team that IFC West is dangerous man it
really is
that was a team I thought about wide
receiver trios - because I believe me
people let us know in the comments miss
them ty just couldn't give cam sudden of
respect ya know the guy is the expert I
got an SMU yeah damn I know what's
intriguing I didn't realize they got it
so I mean for all those people out there
that want to be mad that I didn't pick
Atlanta I mean I I would take the
one-two combination of Denver over the
one-two combination in Atlanta no I
wouldn't okay I just for me it's like
Julio over everything I like Sutton over
Ridley but really I get that Julio is
better than a manual or Demaryius I'm
not arguing that I think I want to steal
a game from the NBA on TNT and I don't
know what I'm gonna start playing it out
of who he play for they do
to Charles Barkley yeah Oh a digit uh
who he play for Sims
well what team is OA did you sue on
right now oh man he signed with somebody
towards the end of last year right
because he went he went a while he was
with the Giants it's a fun game it is a
good game I really thought he was not on
a team Oh what did you sua
is on taking us but yet the Bills Bills
it's there's a lot of guys I bet there
is yeah alright beans not beef yep our
guy tarik Cohen yeah cement he
officially came out and said he's not
Jewish damn I know but he all said he's
never been to a Jewish deli beans not
beef I would like to take tarik cohen
the hebrew in the hebrew and the hammer
and i would like to take him to Katz's
Deli i think he's got to get the right
experience we take two rico n' we get
him some matzo ball soup soup maybe a
corned beef special maybe a little
pastrami do you think Tariq Cohen would
listen I I love Jews and a lot of they
bring to the table food is one of the
ones in one areas where ever had
matzo-ball soup yes it's not bad
okay what about the straw me it's no
it's not my thing too much meat on a
little too thin of a bread I don't like
that much texture have you ever tried it
or did you just look at it and go no no
I have tried it when I was younger and
it was a small bite and I've ever since
to look at it and that was all I need it
is like it's actually really delicious
I'm sure it is I don't like that much
meat in my mouth sorry
BAM put that on a quote card leecher for
it another one for beans not beef
Cameron wake I didn't realize how
dedicated this man was to his body he's
not young how old his camera wake now
like 36 gonna say 37 he's he's like look
yeah I think he's like 96 career sacks
or something like that
in 2005 he decided I am no longer gonna
drink beer I am NOT gonna have fried
foods I'm not doing it he said on 3rd
and 10 when his opponents hurting I want
to be a step ahead even if it's 10 years
of clean diet for that one millisecond
it's worth it for me beer is not going
to change
beer is going to taste the same in ten
years as a taste tomorrow yesterday but
that sack won't yeah I like it I imagine
that Cameron Wake is in beer jail and
when he comes out like he doesn't go
down the beer aisle it doesn't look and
when he comes out after ten years he's
gonna be like they have cherry wheat
hell they have orange vacation beer like
I just imagine he's never looked at beer
but it also makes me think man when
camera wake retires he's gonna be the
party he's gonna happen but he doesn't
have like funnels coming down as now if
I hear he's a pouring beer into it he
says to me even if it's one sack it's
worth it because ten years from now when
I'm not playing I can have all the
cheeseburgers all the beaches all
everything but now is not the time no
it's that speaks to the dedication a lot
of these guys in the league have he's
obsessive obviously and that's why he
looks and plays the way he does it so
yeah like when he remember he had like
three or four sacks on Monday Night
Football in they interview him
afterwards he has that to the point
where yes you could tell why he couldn't
Bend so my arms are so jacked and ripped
I mean it that's a phenomenal success
story coming from Canada doing what he's
done and really at this point of his
career is still a difference maker I
mean still a guy where you gotta go I
don't know if we can leave our tackle
there all game long against this guy I
think what's crazy is he has a lot of
quotes of his teammates being shocked by
it like I can't believe you eat like
this I can't believe you don't drink you
never do anything because for me like I
assume that a lot of NFL athletes have
that mindset I think there is a certain
how many players the NFL do you really
think never eat bad food and never drink
alcohol and are super pure very few
there's a lot of thousand players yeah
right I mean I think I think like okay
let's just go from the locker room like
there's 53 guys in our locker room on
your team okay out most guys are healthy
right
yeah healthy but they're gonna have
beers and snacks out of those 53 I'm
gonna say there's like five guys in
every law a locker room that are
obsessed like I'm trying to break my
body's addiction to glucose like doing
things like that where you're like what
I'm trying to see how long that can go
without one grandma
sugar because when the sugar goes in
your body then your your growth hormone
levels go down and it works together
right I like so there's a few of them
and every super in the weeds about
training some of the supplements they're
taking things like that do you think
they're year-round or do you think when
it's the off season or year around
they're obsessed so about five guys on
every team and I don't think like guys
like this more times than not even
though you and I we think oh when it's
over he's in a party they end up being
just as strict when they're done
retiring it's like the Jerry Rice's is
the world they're like it's Terrell
Owens it's that kind of guy yeah that's
just obsessed he can't it's truly part
of his being as Ellison yeah or phil
simms exactly right
phil has a little bit more of a hungry
appetite than the normal guy but that's
so now I have two things from beans not
beef one I want to take tarik Cohen to a
Jewish deli well to I want to be there
for cam wakes first beer right like that
first sip of beer he'd be great too if
he was like man I haven't had this for
ten years I'm gonna love it he's like
good tequila let's do this alright so
Dion Lewis and Derek Henry came out and
said we're both too good backs were true
the best running backs in the league and
then we're gonna get to your doctor
friend I'm excited about to study your
brain I think he's outside oh I'm
excited but he Dan Lewis said that he
believes him and Derek Henry could be
the best duo in the league I went
through you went through we came with
our best duo's would you like to go
first or second I'll go second okay I'm
not even sure if I know my exact order
yet I to come it's really hard I try to
come on my chart I try to come on my top
five I have Derek Henry and Dion Lewis
right outside the top five okay right
outside the top five I also have se Kwan
and Jonathan Stewart yeah it's just too
early
also in that mix Joe Mixon and Giovanni
Bernard LaShawn McQueen Chris Ivory it's
a lot of one and then not the guy Todd
Gurley and Malcolm Brown like Michael
Brown's really good he's just he's not
you
no it has to be a 2 and it can't also be
you know I looked at like teams like the
New England Patriots it's a committee
there's so many guys cities there right
my number one
Alvin Kamara and Mark Ingram yeah I know
that he has peds it's really hard for me
ok I don't care
I think they compliment each other
perfectly I know it's a flaw you're in
Europe Spanish bothers me my number two
is Atlanta Devonta Freeman and Tevin
Coleman yeah they're perfect
yes number three is a little surprising
hmm I am going Dalvin cook and latavius
Murray I thought they were on the
outside looking in for me I feel like
Dalvin I feel like they're both really
good run of X that's number three gotcha
bye number four is another surprise I'm
going Kareem hunt and Spencer where
Spencer where's coming back I think
Spencer where is a number one on a lot
of teams him and Kareem hunt I really
like together I know you're gonna
disagree no I don't there have my number
five in your top five there I don't know
I'm gonna talk about me or curry mutton
Spencer where would you think about them
I I mean I'm not sure if they're in my
top five I think that's there like for
me it's gonna be like are they five or
six I got my so right there in there
right and then my number five is the
Hebrew on the hammer
Jordan Howard and tarik Cohen because I
think now we're getting that was hard
because I thought about them and I
thought are they better than Derrick
Henry India and lose and I think that I
like to Rico in more than I like Dion
Lewis okay cuz I think he's I think he's
a more of like a weapon at the back
fielder and that Derrick Henry I feel
like he's he's special
right I just trust Jordan Howard more on
an every down basis yeah but they're
they're so close like I have Derrick
Henry and Dion Lewis six seven and then
five it's all rotation I know so mine
goes New Orleans Atlanta Minnesota
Kansas City Chicago
what is your top five do a Hoosier
number one my number one I'm giving it
to Elena because of mark Ingram's drug
tests okay then where are you putting
New Orleans I'm gonna put New Orleans -
okay so you are wanted to are the same
teams just flip I just can't give him
number one because of the PD I can't do
it
and I just don't have the power okay
okay so that's gone it's a three number
three what are you thinking man this is
it stuff all right so from here on out
let me just tell you my teams that I'm
with all right the bangles Titans bears
Chiefs those are the four teams
remaining for me god I look at it I
think I'm going to go bangles three so
you're gonna put Joe Mixon and Giovanni
but not hydrate I think I am and it's
not sitting I'm sitting here like I'm
not like saying this is written in stone
I know I don't know everything in
football I do think Joe Mixon is special
talent and Giovanni Bernard I think it's
pretty special as well
because injuries and all this right it's
his first year back from ACL but so I
I'm giving that I guess a little bit
maybe a hair more respect because of
what I think Joe Mixon could totally be
and what Giovanni Bernard has been and I
know last year he was coming back from
ACL he wasn't totally himself so I'm
putting this yeah I'm not mad at it for
I'm going with the Titans they're you're
gonna put the Titans later I am I think
I'm gonna go there with our man Dion
Lewis first of all I think he's a great
addition he's a great complement to the
way that I think Derek Henry runs and of
course he's gonna be a great cog for the
Matt Lafleur offense yes who's gonna be
able to use him as I said last week
Titans are gonna be dangerous that's an
offense my thing is to if if they need a
nickname yeah I don't know where we can
go with it but something with twins like
the movie twins Arnold Schwarzenegger
and Danny DeVito
it's Derek Hillary next to Dion Lewis
looks ridiculous hilarious like he could
put him on his shoulder and put a trench
coat and they can go buy movie tickets
they really could yes I go there I first
I think we're gonna see Derek Henry have
a phenomenal year because it's the first
year he's gonna get the workman's share
of the that carries even though variable
did come out and said we're not doing 30
carries for anybody yeah I can't imagine
that I don't think that's a good formula
for really anybody this day and age
anymore I think those days are gone like
30 carries the Leonard fournette Ezekiel
Elliot's will get the 22 to 24 carries a
game but rarely gonna go above that but
I do I just
that's a special combo right there and
who you picking for five I think I'm
going to go with Jordan Howard and them
and them and the he's Rico any more than
ever I am I'm gonna go with them mention
the bench yes I like curry mutton
Spencer we're I think they're on the
outside just looking in just barely no
Dalvin cook latavius and I did think
about them I think to where I looked at
them and just said man Dalvin hasn't
really done anything quite yet and he's
coming off injury so I got it was like a
double thing for me yeah he wanted to
put sake one in there do say Quan and
Jay Stewart were on that list short list
on the outside looking in but I really
realistically looked at it I said I
can't put Johnathan Stewart up there
with some of these other duo's that's
the really the really problem but yeah
Jordan Howard come on man
I mean he led football rushing two years
ago or was he ii ii ii ii again this
year right now so he's at two years in
the top two last year with no passing
game no passing game no right and he was
guys were talking about him going I've
never seen anyone play with a shoulder
injury that was amazing so I think it's
only gonna get better and especially if
their offensive line stays healthy and
then you have guys like to Rico and to
who didn't really even get to show what
he could be as a running back last year
because they had no receivers so they
had to go hey running back you have to
be our best receiver too and so he
didn't get to show everything there so
that's my top five they both had like
amazing players like Tariq Cohen had
like one little scream boy at that toss
sweep that wanted against the Steelers
remember in the home game there and then
Jordan Howard had like that incredible
run against the Ravens and overtime
right it sort of was Oh miss phenomenal
they're they're fun to watch
Jordan Howard I'm just texting me this
weekend he was like hey you in the city
and I was like I'm in Texas and I was
like damn it
I could've hung out with Jordan Howard
this weekend that would be an awesome
that's cool yeah he's my friend did he's
the hammer yeah and then I could be his
Hebrew yes that's why I was calling you
yeah he was yes all right so we're gonna
bring in now Tim Bergsma he's gonna come
on guys thank you so much love you so
much
hit us up on social as always at Sims
and Lefko but for now let's bring in Tim
all right Tim is in the building he is
here he is young he is spry he is happy
and his brain is active and is
functioning at high love
he shocked us cuz we don't expect people
to have these bigger jobs and have
brains be this young how dare you be
young like this no they say they say in
order to be young you got to be good
right told me he's got this neuro doctor
coming from neuro peak Pro and I was
definitely expecting like a 65 year old
do a lab coat alright so what do you
guys got going on and how did you get in
touch with with Sims over here yeah
quick disclaimer I am NOT our doctor
gacho's doctor dr. Tim Royer same name
but yeah so got connected with the Sims
through a mutual friend Greg Roscoe
right legendary saved my career that's
why the people on the podcast had no
umber
actually could I ask Chris has always
talked about how this guy can like
isolate things from someone that's in
the medical community yeah tell me about
Roscoe I'm sorry we're going somewhere
else but I've never heard anyone else
talk about him before no he's he's great
and basically everyone that you talked
to who knows him in the sports community
swears by him and almost to the point
where they're gonna be pissed that we're
talking about him on the podcast cuz
they want him for himself exactly right
you know I'm we're talking with a couple
golfers that like yeah you can either
hit me at my home next week or hit me
when I'm at Greg's
Wow and so you know in Denver if you're
in Denver and a lot of athletes fly into
Denver I know several times a week he's
the guy to to make it happen because you
know what he does is it's very similar
philosophy to what we do where it's the
whole body's connected and he's working
on you know muscular and skeletal issues
to then impact things that are go even
way beyond massage I know people don't
realize all that stuff but yes go ahead
sorry no you're good like he'll deal
with it can help digestion you can help
our Paralyzed people all those things
right am i good speaking wrongly here
whatever it may be bodies with things
that you're little issues you have with
your body people don't realize that the
muscular system has so much to do with
the body functioning correctly right
more than just looking good in their
tank top you guys take it more from the
mental perspective
yeah from the brain functioning
perspective even so he works kind of
body up right and what we're gonna do is
we're gonna work brain out hmm
and so by optimizing the autonomic
nervous system the part of your body
that takes in cues from your environment
and says do I want to go fast
or do I want to go slow optimizing that
so that if you're sitting at your office
and trying to come up with some sort of
answer a creative solution your body
isn't reacting like you're in a
life-or-death situation getting chased
by a lion he's able to activate that
calm creative focus right and I've seen
some videos I've seen Kirk Cousins I've
seen Tobias Harris I've seen a bunch of
NBA players how do you guys work with
athletes how are you gonna work with mr.
Chris Sims I'm looking out for me well
I'm not longer an athlete too so that's
where I was trying to say to the people
out there too this is more about just
athletes I think this is gonna be
something just from my little based
knowledge I'm gonna learn a lot more
here when we get done with the podcast
but from my base knowledge everything
he's explained to me this point is gonna
help me with life and live healthier and
whatever your job is it's going to make
you better at it because your brain will
function better I guess that's how yeah
absolutely so if you take just think of
that autonomic nervous system I'm gonna
keep using that same phrase you're gonna
become experts at it by the time it's
all said if it is going way too fast
you're gonna experience things like
anxiety maybe OCD migraines happen when
it's very very fast it's very very slow
you get things like depression or ADHD
where a person's unable to click into
focus right so what we can do is whether
someone's suffering with one of those
issues that's kind of way out there or
they just want to be a little bit more
creative focus or a little bit less
stressed like they're already pretty
good but they want to be the best right
they engage with our training and so
with Kirk and Tobias what they do is
they have units that they run at their
home and we have coaches that will login
to them via zoom or Skype and walk them
through their training and their
trainings all about brain computer
interface it's about getting the
electrical firing of the brain
connected to a computer in the
technology and then laying the
technology give the operant conditioning
the positive and negative feedback so
that the brain operates with more
creativity less stress you know just
like you can learn calculus or Spanish
we can teach your brain how to focus
okay so within that okay so you just say
somebody does have too much stress what
is it that you do to lessen it is it I
mean what are the exercises explain some
of that a little bit of what you do yeah
absolutely so it's the part of the brain
that it's the autonomic side so it's not
necessarily hey block the bad harness
the good I think happy thoughts
what we're doing is we're actually
engaging with the electrical firing of
the brain so stress waves are known as
high beta from about 20 Hertz which is
an oscillation per second and higher so
we do is we literally hook your brain up
to a DVD player right anytime those
waves are getting high instantaneously
that DVD pauses as those fluctuate down
the DVD plays and that works as a yes
and no so the example I often use out of
a two-year-old nephew right and when he
was first learning how to talk he would
point at a car and go car and we'd all
go yeah yes that's a car then he'd put
an airplane and go car back no that's an
airplane well over time he gets enough
yeses and noes now he knows what a car
is he's really good at you know telling
you what a car and just in that same way
that a two-year-old brain can learn the
definition of a car our brains through
the right yes as the right knows the
right feedback can learn how to operate
at its best right so you were telling a
story about Kirk Cousins before I'll
know if you can tell that again so there
was this like the first test with Kirk
was Star Wars no so that's that's so
Kirk has been working with dr. rorish
since he was at Michigan State Wow so
holy crap yeah I know it was that long
yep he's been working a long time and
he's done a ton of work publicly with
with dr. Royer we don't share all of our
athletes stories but Kirk is someone who
is very public with what he does with us
and it was about halfway through senior
season and he asked dr. Royer he got in
touch with him and we just wanted to
work on a few things they had Ohio State
at the shoe who coming up in in I think
there's two weeks from the Dodgers as
this as preparation not to
like he could do it like the week of to
kind of get your mind and the synapses
firing all that yeah so if you think
about it like working out your body if I
come in and I'm 45 pounds overweight
I've got like a base layer that I have
to put in just to shed that extra weight
and then from there it's fine-tuning
right it's I want to be at the pinnacle
of fitness same is true here there's a
base layer to kind of get the years and
decades of kind of junk out of the way
yeah and then it's fine-tuning and
really getting that brain and body at
the absolute best
so senior year week of a shoe and he
needed some fine-tuning yeah and so the
first thing that doc works with them on
is just breathing and it seems so simple
but the way we take in oxygen can impact
our autonomic nervous system so what
what he does is we do diaphragmatic
breathing now can we do it yeah yeah we
can do it so if you if you see I used to
do a little of this every now and then
but go ahead yeah so basically the
average American breeze 12 to 16 breasts
a minute and we do that shallow breaths
each of our lungs is has 300 million
alveoli so 600 million alveoli to
saturate with oxygen and then dissipate
the carbon dioxide when we're breathing
12 breaths a minute we're not optimizing
those right so we want to do is drop
that rate to about six breaths a minute
damn breathing from our diaphragm so
from our family yep so if your shoulders
are moving it's not going right okay if
you put that hand on the stomach it's a
nice deep in all right questions if you
don't have your hand on your stomach and
you're living a normal life are you
still doing six so do you have to be
like get back to six Tim so the analogy
that we'll use on this is it's like
clearing out the apps on your iPhone is
you wake up you know literally you know
you talk to somebody you maybe have a
morning meeting you email phone call
breathe you keep going lunch another
meeting you have to film your podcast
breathe because what that's doing is
it's signaling to your body hey this
isn't an emergency you're not drowning
you're not suffocating this is okay so
settle back in yeah and we've all we've
all had that experience where we're
working so hard that we can't we get in
a block and we show everything and then
what do we do we go for a walk or we
a nap where we shower and all of a
sudden you're like oh there's that idea
right it's because we're pushing
ourselves fast fast fast fast fast and
then it's not until we allow and push
our body slower where we can access that
calm creative focus right that makes
sense it's that's where I'm interested
I'm interested so okay so even this
Atlas add to this first of all sleep
right because this is another huge thing
so where does the sleep part of it all
tie into all this as far as better
performance whatever it may be
absolutely that's a you know that's a
for our segment probably but too short
right so sleep impacts our daytime and
to call it sleep is kind of crazy I
never would I say hey what did you do
yesterday I was awake you know like that
sounds crazy but we say oh you know I
was asleep from midnight to 7:00 or
whatever it was and but what's happening
during sleep is the first half asleep
you get a lot of deep sleep which is
where the body is recovering then
ideally at your body's nadir at its
coldest point which happens right around
2:30 or 3:00 a.m. okay
it starts heating back up and that's
where you get REM sleep right during REM
sleep is where your brain shrinks toxins
are flushed away you dream you problem
solve memories or consolidate the sweat
maybe a little at night to potentially
issue so when we're not when we sleep
properly we're getting all of this
beautiful recovery when stuff gets off
in our sleep or you know when our
daytime brain starts impacting our
nighttime brain that's when you get a
lot of people who say hey I wake up at
3:00 a.m. which it's no surprises 3:00
a.m. because that's right when that body
starting to shift yeah and when you're
in REM sleep your brain super alive
right super active right so if I have
kind of under riding anxiety yeah what
happens is my brain just pops up happens
to me all the time and wakes me up I
take a 315 P and I my brain starts going
it's start going about left goes into
the podcast or the show I gotta do for
NBC Sports and I can't shut that Bath up
I don't so you wake up at 3:15 a lot I
do and I have a hard time and my wife
knows this is one of the biggest reasons
I'm intrigued by this too
it's really been an issue for me like
turning my brain off I can't turn it off
all of a sudden um it's 3:30 in the
morning and the show topics and things
we're gonna talk about I'm already
formulating my conversation and house to
know that he cares that so yeah but so
that's I don't even know why I was just
saying but that happens to me that's
interests yeah I'll get my diagnosis
yeah I mean we were gonna look at his
brain here soon so I bet we will see
indicators of that yes because the last
thing you need at 3:00 is to be thinking
about the podcast because all that's
going to do is determine and so the idea
it's kind of we want you to be where
your feet are right there's a time for
planning there's a time for looking back
but when it's time to be focused and be
here and present and in the moment I
don't want to be thinking about you know
for instance me my flight today or many
things tomorrow or the meeting I just
had earlier I want to be here and
present and left go podcast exact right
okay all right so I have I have so many
good but he was gonna say so like you're
gonna look at his brain yep how do you
look at his brain so we're gonna do is
we're gonna hook up in a medical-grade
electroencephalogram so an EEG okay so
just like an EKG will measure your heart
or an EMG can measure muscles we're
gonna measure the electricity of the
brain oh and you're gonna put like nodes
on his head yeah he's gonna have two
grounds on his ears and then we'll look
at three different areas of his brain
today we look at center-left if you can
do it here yeah yeah pictures up to him
sure yeah podcast for the Instagram yeah
absolutely it's actually been featured
in GQ with Couric that look the lead on
it so we can say that it has been I know
this isn't gonna be like total across
the board but like there is there
certain things you continually find with
athletes or like certain things you
continually find with Wall Streeters or
whatever it may be
yeah what are the some of the
differences there that you see with
certain jobs or whatever maybe
absolutely so there's kind of a I would
say a strength category and a tendency
for weakness category so when we have
looked at someone who's been number one
in the world for tennis over multiple
years another individual who's number
one of the world for golf over multiple
years an individual who is the MVP of
the NBA who had a very long NBA career
right they all have things in common on
the plus side on the positive side
they're stress waves they're anxiety
that we were talking about those
fascinating waves are almost
non-existent wherever they are never
seeing a lion it doesn't matter if you
know or in golf it doesn't matter if
it's a putt on 18 of the Masters worth
you know however many million dollars or
it's a putt on Wednesday during a
practice round that putt is that putt is
that putt yeah that's amazing you know
that free throws every throws that free
throw like this is amaze you when you
get that feedback back it's it's
incredible to see it and it's what's
more incredible to me is when I can
spend 30 minutes with someone and look
at their brain and say hey based on this
brain you're gonna have the tendency for
this and that person says oh you're
describing me Yeah right
you know it's like Jesus and the woman
at the well yes but you know I get a
little bit of yeah you do yeah shocked
but it's because these things that we
experience are stem from a physiological
reaction what about the negatives yeah
so what we see especially in long season
sports so basketball and hockey is that
because of their sleep disruption
playing 41 games on the road 82 games
total right is where stealing sleep away
from them and sleep in brain health feed
into each other so when one is good the
other one tends to be good and then when
you disrupt one the other one tends to
suffer so their brains and even their
testosterone when we do hormone sampling
is goes down throughout the course of
the season Wow
and ESPN actually did a thing about the
sleep and how there's kind of the
unwinnable games right and they talked
to dr. Royer about it he was like yeah
it's not only do they schedule in on
winnable games but they also are putting
these individuals at risk for injury
sure that's why you see so many more
injuries on the second half of the
season right because testosterone was
compromised due to really lack of sleep
and overuse I feel like the last three
years there's
movement of acceptance of sleep I think
Arianna Huffington was like the first
one that's like here's a book and it's
about sleep and I've gone on dates with
people and if they say they don't they
only get four hours I don't talk to them
Tom Brady's come out talking about sleep
I feel like there was a long run 10-15
years of going
I don't need your weakness like a badge
of honor and I and it has gone
completely the other way now my question
is was dr. Royer saying that all along
and now everyone else is like or was he
part of the movement - you know I would
say he's always valued it I would say oh
the more we learn about sleep it's
impossible to ignore
right because the links that it has
towards memory loss towards Alzheimer's
towards all these things not just today
and my ability to perform my job today
but my ability to be alive in my 70s 80s
90s all links back to sleep
Sam alright so you didn't how many hours
am I supposed to sleep so actually
another thing that you are gonna do that
your family has done you're all doing it
they're doing it we can hook you up
we'll get you go how you sleep is we're
actually measuring sleep so we have this
we call it our mobile polysomnographic
or it is gonna hook up and it's not like
a Fitbit that's just measuring are you
tossing or turning but it's actually
gonna stage out your sleep tell you how
much deep sleep how much REM sleep how
much light sleep
how much awakening after sleep onset
have you had and what we do is we have a
normative database where you run that
against a thousand other people your age
and we say are you getting enough sleep
for those stages because you might be a
person who's hyper efficient who in
seven hours can get the amount of sleep
other people do in eight you might be
the other way you might need nine or ten
hours of sleep just to get what normal
people do an eight that information is
valuable so you know your sleep isn't
equal to your sleep isn't able to my
sleep
yeah I think you're a pretty average
sleeper I am I'm well I mean my wife is
like somebody that needs eight hours or
she can't function good question so he's
dealing with like a tough terrain here
like he's got away games when he sleeps
the wife I mean if you wanna play the
audio yeah just kind of a lawnmower
that she snores she's definitely part of
my issue to where I don't wear earplugs
anymore but I have a noise machine in
the Ruka right so I've had a deal with
that she's realized that if she doesn't
eat late and especially as long as she's
healthy later she doesn't snore as much
so yeah yeah it's been getting better
but that is yes one of the obstacles I'm
having to deal with yes sleep
environment is huge
I know actually I've always said this so
I live I live in New York and I live two
blocks from a fire station and I've
always said it's annoying when it goes
by but it has to be impacting me while
I'm sleeping like if at 3 o'clock a fire
truck goes by I might not wake up but it
has to be impacting me somehow you would
assume so and but we don't know how much
it's impacting you until we actually
look at your sleep because you could
both wait coming over to sleep over I
can send the technology I need to come
over myself but you know we could all
wait cup and say hey how'd you sleep
last night
seven 7.58 but we're just comparing that
to other nights of sleep that'll be rad
you know we have people who say oh yeah
I'm sleeping an eight we get their brain
we get their breathing we get some of
these other things going they go hey
remember when I set out sleeping today I
was sleeping a four I didn't know that
this kind of sleep was possible I didn't
know that this was I thought this was
you know four children could only sleep
like this yeah what do you think so
we're this is I know I know I have a few
friends that do it I'm not gonna add all
these people because I think that some
of them like he was saying oh that
grades private they don't and then they
also like you're gonna have them on the
podcast I mean no people are gonna know
about them I get like I need the same
about Greg Ross cop and the m80 out in
Denver same type of thing but where when
you get athletes to come to you what are
they usually trying to accomplish more
than anything like what's goal number
one have they realized they have
deficiencies are they just looking to
get better any way they can I would say
you just nailed the two right one is I'm
in the 95th 98th 99th percentile I want
to get to the 99.99% I'll write I want
to squeeze every bit of juice out of me
I have right now the other one would be
you can fix my sleep yeah right and when
we say hey we can we can help yeah you
there's a lot there you're gonna have to
do a lot but it's gonna be work but yeah
but this can this can help guys like
eyes light up
yeah right I just I think this is the
wave of the future I really do that's
why I'm excited to meet with you and get
tested here and I just think it's gonna
be you know we're in the age of the
changing dynamic of sports and sports
science and we're seeing all these you
know just new-age things come to light
and players are pushing the limits yeah
and I think this is gonna be kind of the
next phase especially in the NFL for
coaches players whatever it may be and
and I mean I'm not wrong to say it would
work for the lawyers and the doctors of
the worlds right either like did you
have any commonalities between some of
those jobs and Oliver you were like
that's so strange they're like that like
whether is doctors or lawyers or
anything yes so there's two numbers that
we look at yeah one we kind of described
as our gas pedal is how how hard are you
going is that pedal on the floor the
other one is the brake pedal yeah what
we find especially in lawyers also sales
people business owners is that that gas
is down and they have no brake and they
can do that they can do that for months
they can do that for years but they're
they're borrowing or they're stealing
from somewhere and oftentimes that's
that long-term health yes and we'll run
into people who are incredibly
successful right
but they've they've stolen from sleep
they've stolen from these other things
and now they're experiencing memory
issues and they say hey I would give
anything I would give it all back if I
could remember you know my grandkids
names or you know because honestly is
there a way to start that yeah it's by
if it's by improving the brain now so
that we can sleep better now yeah that
we can keep it strong so it doesn't get
to that point it's so weak it's
forgetting [ __ ] exactly and and we're
working out of a sustainable focus not
this hyper overactive folk right right
and have you my last one for me is have
you had anybody that's like blown you
guys away felt like you called your
other co-workers in the office or like
he is off the charts have there been
cases like that
there
are a few and are they typically like
high performers almost always and it's
it's incredible there's kind of the
genetic standpoint there's also the
epigenetic standpoint of it but they're
oftentimes people who have two
high-performing parents who then they
themselves are high-performing who have
kind of grown up it's usually the kind
of the stars have to align right for
that individual I would say 99% of
people we look at have something they
could improve some more than others but
yeah every so often I mean we'll do
we'll look at people who are entering
the NBA yeah and they are fantastic from
our standpoint but maybe the reason they
have gotten to that point isn't their
athleticism is that they're getting
every square inch out of what they have
and other people will be you know
starting pro careers and they'll only be
50% of the way towards their ceiling
they might be athletically right but
they're not mentally they're not from a
visual processing or recovery or any of
these standpoint right makes me almost
value them more because they have so
many more things to improve upon that we
haven't even seen yet that's what I
always say whenever I'm doing
assessments I'm like hey the best thing
that can happen today is I find a couple
things that are inefficient yeah because
then we can improve those and who knows
who you can be aware yeah man I'm hoping
you Ace this test we find out today I
don't know if you're gonna find out
today but that you have like listen
you're using like 20% like be like man
this is great
the Sims and Sims left cause not to
improve incredibly yeah but tell your
wife that she's making your sleep
environment so difficult I trust me I've
been here if we just come out and say
yep she's a pain in the ass she took it
well though yes she did she's been good
she's actually had been taking I mean
paying attention to where her head lays
and all these things right that's great
so finally we're making some waves here
we'll see but I I think even without her
I still have sleep issues sure so that's
why I want to and then of course I want
to keep my brain healthy and going I've
had concussions whether it was football
or just being a young idiot and I'm
keep my brain healthy and functioning
from that as well Tim we appreciate
Chang's been wearing people go if they
want to learn more about what you guys
have going on yes
neuro peak procom is the best there's a
spot there's a neuro peak that's a
supplement do not get us twisted with
that Oh Carol peak procom you'll see our
video that pop was thinking about those
other supplements I see like alpha brain
and all these ones are supposed to
improve brain cognition do supplements
do that there are there are some
supplements that can be good okay what
we would say is make that the cherry on
top if there's not the fixer if you're
you know having eight beers before you
go to bed sleep in four hours eating you
know chips and yeah and then you're like
oh this is gonna help me maximize my
focus like we're kidding ourselves
gotcha but if you're doing everything
you're eating a good diet you're
sleeping well your brain is trained
you're you know engaging and heart rate
variability training all these things
and you want still to try another little
boost
potentially potentially now I'd also say
look at the brain and see what it's
doing see how it impacts that right but
ultimately make that the cherry awesome
Noro Peak Pro Tim I appreciate you bro
thanks - thank you thank you ma'am